okay today is all about healthy food i
love running marathons and playing sport
so this subject's very close to my heart
healthy food has a bit of a bad
reputation for being slightly boring and
bland but it doesn't have to be and
that's one of the keys to maintaining a
good diet you need to make food that's a
pleasure to eat as well as being healthy
packed with flavor here's more of my
ultimate healthy food
for breakfast my secret to amazing
healthy granola made in minutes and full
of goodness
next a quick and easy healthy lunch
bursting with flavor and brimming with
lean protein steamed mussels with cherry
tomatoes and saffron crisp breads
for dinner incredible spicy lamb chops
with superfoods broccoli and burger
wheat and a vitamin pack healthy mango
sundae
proof that food that is good for you can
taste great
these are more of my ultimate healthy
recipes breakfast lunch and dinner
first up my homemade granola for
breakfast
every time i put
a healthy recipe together a healthy dish
it needs a bit of a treat so this is a
lovely stunning
get up and go fresh granola first thing
in the morning the treat here
is in that little baby
honey
so that sweetens it
so just start off with 200 ml
of delicious honey
into a pan just to warm up in she goes
now
i know these are a chef's favorite but
it makes all the difference especially
for breakfast a fresh
vanilla pod and i think of the way that
i use herbs to add
flavour to soups and salads
i'd like to think that vanilla does
exactly the same
scrape out all those wonderful seeds in
now
the staple of the granola
is the oats
next
puff rice delicious
crunchy
but light
and fluffy next add wheat bran and your
seeds pumpkin sunflower and linseed
and then almonds
incredible
that nice heavy weight
from the nut bunch
now bring the honey to the boil
slowly drizzle that amazing honey
in
give that a really good mix
coat the granola with the hot honey just
slowly churn it
using the outside of the
bowl you can see it just getting nice
and sticky
once the granola is completely coated in
honey it's ready to bake
now spread the mix on baking paper i'm
gonna season it lightly with a touch of
salt on top
the salt throughout
dries up the oats and the honey will
roast
color and glaze
the granola
nice into the oven for 25 to 30 minutes
10 minutes into the cooking simply run a
spoon across the top to turn the mix and
ensure it's crunchy all over
smell that light
roast
look at the color honestly look it's
crispy
it's delicious
now i'm gonna tart it up and put some
lovely dried cranberries
that just gives us chewy
sweet flavor delicious
and then finally
these beautiful berries
goji berries goji berries are high in
antioxidants and have been eating china
for centuries for their healing
properties but you can add any dried
fruit you like the cranberry
and the goji berries gives it that nice
chewy rich texture
to the granola
now this is the best way
to store it it looks incredible
really incredible
look at that
now
eat well stay well
right
milk
my homemade crunchy granola it looks
good tastes good and it's packed with
healthy grains superfood berries and
seeds it's incredibly good for you too a
breakfast for champions
next i'll be showing you a fantastic
healthy lunch and dinner
there are no magic ingredients just
great fresh food here's a closer look at
what you'll need to make them
[Music]
first up for lunch one of my favorite
ingredients mussels they're great value
an excellent source of nutrients and
lean protein and they are so versatile
you can poach them grill them or bake
them but i'm going to steam them with
cherry tomatoes pancetta sherry and
chili for lunch
[Music]
my next healthy ingredient is bulgur
wheat richer in protein fiber and
minerals than many other grains the
nutty flavored bulgur wheat is made by
par boiling drying then grinding whole
wheat it's fantastic in puddings in
stuffings or in salads like the charred
broccoli one i'll be serving for dinner
[Music]
finally not strictly an ingredient but
it certainly adds flavor the griddle pan
perfect for grilling almost anything
with minimum oil and maximum taste plus
excess fat just drains away you can find
them for as little as 10 pounds trust me
it's worth the investment and takes veg
meat and fish to another healthy level
chefs are renowned for working all hours
and having unhealthy lifestyles but i
try to keep myself fit and eat healthily
and it's not as difficult as you might
think so however busy your life is i'm
going to prove to you you don't need to
always go for fast food or ready meals
it's easy to cook fantastic healthy
meals at home here's my ultimate healthy
lunch fast to cook but crammed with
flavor a delicious saffron flatbread
with mussels it doesn't get any healthy
than that first job the super easy
saffron flatbread
[Music]
put the saffron
into the bowl
and a couple of teaspoons of hot water
that starts to infuse
the saffron
and so you can maximize on the colour
across your flatbeds
to make the dough simply add plain flour
a pinch of salt and pepper to a bowl and
then pour in a dash of olive oil
that makes the dough nice and silky and
rich your saffron water you'll see how
concentrated it is now
and you'll need cold water
simply need to bring the dough together
mop up
all your flour
you can see now
the saffron's activated it's got that
really nice color
beautiful
use your wrist
and just knead it nicely we'll do now is
smoothing out
the gluten strands
push
and tuck in
push and tuck in and each every time you
do this getting softer you just sort of
form
like this perfect
beautiful
dough
it smells delicious that saffron is very
powerful
now
sit that in your bowl cover it with clim
film let it rest for 10 to 15 minutes
this relaxes the dough making it easier
to roll and gives it time to infuse with
the saffron i'll cut that into three and
then roll them nice and thinly now
lightly flour the surface
and then
just
bring that
to like a perfect ball
on the board
once you've got that nice ball your
rolling pin
and just roll it out
now
it doesn't get any simpler than that
and just lightly
flour that on top
a little salt
cooking the flatbread is easy just pop
in a hot dry pan and they're ready in
minutes as it hits the pan it starts the
blister
she's ready
for turning
beautiful get that color on there
now you want it nice and crisp almost
blistering on both sides because it's
nice and thin
it's cooked once browned on both sides
just cool on a rack flatbread's done now
on to the muscles now the secret
behind cooking
great muscles
is in the speed you cook
the key is to chop and prep your
ingredients before you start cooking
first thing pancetta i want it quite
chunky if you can't get pancetta i
always like to use a sort of streaky
bacon
because i want to sort of render all
that flavour
at the streaky bacon
now tomatoes garlic and chili
cherry tomatoes they're just going in
whole
the garlic
just crush the garlic
so all that flavor comes out chilli
i want some heat in here
that's everything prepped now to get it
cooked little touch
of olive oil
pancetta in
pancetta takes moments once it's brown
and crisp put your garlic chili and
whole cherry tomatoes into the pan
mussels go in
okay and i'm using dry sherry
i think it works better in this recipe
than white wine which is classically
used at this stage
then oregano finely chopped stalks and
all i'll go on
and then just give that
a little mix
and we'll see those muscles
start to open lid goes on
you've got to lock in that flavour
gotta lock in that heat the muscles will
take four to five minutes to steam in
the meantime cut your flatbreads into
strips
crispy
and crunchy
now the mussels
wow that is incredible
my goodness me
[Music]
now that is one lunch i definitely don't
want to miss
healthy and delicious
doesn't get any better than that
incredible
steamed mussels with saffron flatbreads
made in minutes and packed with protein
and vitamins this is one fast food meal
that really is healthy
[Music]
healthy is all about balance fresh
home-cooked food in sensible portions
with a few treats now and again my
ultimate healthy dinner is a great
balance of protein carbs vegetables and
fruit but doesn't compromise on taste or
flavor
the key to healthy eating is to have a
host of wholesome recipes up your sleeve
so you're never short of inspiration
joining me to create this healthy dinner
is jack's twin sister holly
we've got aromatic lean lamb chops with
char grill broccoli and burger wheat
salad for dessert it's healthy mango
sundae
holly
[Music]
then i can help daddy with the dessert
yes please and the lamb cutlets
now
we all know that you love desserts yeah
yeah we'll do a little
yogurt parfait with some macerated
fruits
so the first thing i'd like you to do is
take a tablespoon
of icing sugar dust that over the fruits
good
now sad enough that's perfect thank you
zest the orange over the fruits and
what's going to happen now it's going to
start to sort of marinate i'm going to
put some basil in there
that'll make it really flavoursome
fresh puzzle in
and then we need to give that little mix
up
i'm gonna squeeze
some fresh orange juice in there
nice and gently
okay
how gorgeous do those berries look now
very
so we just leave them just marinate okay
and that's what we call
macerated berries
now for the mango sundae
right mangoes in please
i love mangoes
nice
now they're naturally sweet okay
on
oh
that smells incredible
now how fresh
does that smell very now you'd love art
right yeah i do so you're gonna put
these together so a nice little dollop
of mango at the bottom nice and slowly
once each glass has a layer of mango
puree at the bottom
spoon over a layer of thick natural
yoghurt and alternate until the glass is
full
well done now they're yummy from there
you get your berries
you sit your berries on top
they taste so fresh
but now they've been marinated and the
berries have been slightly macerated and
then finally look
get your icing sugar and just tap
on top
they
look it's beautiful
now they sit in the fridge to get nice
and chilled okay
so
if i take three
and promise not to sneeze
and you take one open the fridge door
good job
dessert's chilling in the fridge now for
the super simple main course to go with
the aromatic lamb chops a tasty char
grill broccoli and bulgur wheat salad
to cook the bulgur wheat just simmer
until tender then drain
to give the broccoli a char grilled
flavor simply cook with salt in a hot
dry pan until smoky and tender
for a quick and easy aromatic dressing
mix together harissa paste with either
buttermilk or creme fraiche and add
chopped mint simple as that
to serve thoroughly dress your broccoli
and burger wheat and finish with more
fresh mint leaves
dessert ready and salad is done now for
the aromatic grilled lamb chops
how much do you love lamb holes
a lot a lot on a scale of one to ten
ten okay these lamb chops are gonna be
delicious
first i'm gonna marinate them i'll start
putting the spices in yeah first one
coriander coriander good so a teaspoon
of coriander seeds in a little touch of
what's that human human well done cumin
in
one of daddy's favorites
turmeric chew me a teaspoon of that in
there
now
a little touch
of salt
and then i want you to start grinding
that down while i get the ginger and the
garlic
give that a nice little mix
please for daddy
that looks amazing after that get the
garlic lay it flat
and look
it almost purees the garlic so we get a
nice paste
see underneath sorry about dirting your
nails
it's okay
i just smell like garlic now nothing
wrong with that
the more you smell of garlic
the less the boys are gonna date you
sorry
right now the ginger
makes it sort of
spicy
and fruity now get the ginger and do
exactly the same with the ginger when
you grate it like this it turns into the
most amazing
ginger puree i figured
come on holly put some muscle into it
good girl
nice see all that there you got the back
of the knife
now i'm gonna drizzle some olive oil in
there okay and you bring that together
as a paste for daddy there you go
go on stuck on no it'll come off
nice
good girl
now
that smells incredible that is a
delicious paste
so i'm gonna tip
all that marinade on
to the lamb
and then i want you to rub it all in to
those lamb chops
then we go get your hands in there my
girl
come on holes
so look you get them in there then you
rub
all that marinade
the flavor inside these chops come on
holly that's right come on
your jumper's fine
just
smell that
nice
and the earlier you do this the better
the turmeric is starting to stain
the lamb chops they're not even cooked
yet yet they smell delicious yeah
what do you like honestly oh my nails
oh my nails
delicious after marinating from 10
minutes to overnight but if you can't
wait to get your hands on them you can
grill the chops strain away gas nice and
high and grilling them
is going to make them slightly healthier
so
lamb on
first one
in
we'll slide that in
alongside is that so you sit more in the
pan that's right what i want to do is
get those really nice
grill marks on there
[Music]
see
come on
now we're going to cook them
three sides
one side up flip it and then on the back
see this bit here yeah i'm gonna grill
it on there as well
[Music]
now if you could get the yogurt out of
the fridge please daddy
nice
some fresh mint
i want you to pick
the mint
please and give it a little chop and mix
it in with a yogurt smells amazing
doesn't it
so yogurt
in
chop up
the mint please
have a look
at the color
of the lamb
[Music]
how nice
are they
they smell incredible
grilling them this way they cook so much
quicker
okay it's a lot healthier
smell those
beautiful you excited yes barry
good eric and megan will like those i
hope so
[Music]
see what i'm doing i'm standing the
chopped stuff yeah
yeah we're not going to dry out this way
is that chopped enough try a bit more
that's fine and then mix it
into the yogurt please darling this
isn't too hard is it dad not assault my
darling
how would you know when they're done
nice and pink three and a half to four
minutes each side
medium
six minutes well done
eight or nine minutes
how would you like your landmine darling
medium rare that's what i always go for
a lamb cutlet at its best
will be medium red off with the gas
okay
it's got a lovely
lovely flavor
okay
look at that
wow
i'm in heaven
i'll carry the lamb
and the yogurt if you get the bowl of
wheat and the broccoli they're done that
smells incredible it really does
fast and easy to make packed with
goodness and utterly delicious with a
bit of kitchen know-how you have my
ultimate healthy dinner on the table in
just 30 minutes
[Music]
the perfect meal for any busy family so
excited i could smell it from a mile
away oh really should i go get this
stuff
why not oh can we start serving she's
dying to show her desserts they are tell
oh yes please
oh wow that's very fancy look how proud
she is they look neat gorgeous
all right holes they look amazing they
do beautiful oh look at the colors it's
kind of blue pass it
but after you've eaten all your broccoli
that's a long time away nice and healthy
and she got her hands dirty for the
first time in 13 years
it's delicious really really lovely
there are loads more great home cooking
recipes on my app cook with me you can
find it in the app store good luck